Okay, so you created your first relationship. This is how
we get objects to communicate with each other. And this is
where things get really interesting. Because of the relationship between the
parent object Festival and the child object, Attendee, you can now
aggregate all sorts of useful information. For example, if you want to
know how many tickets you sold, you can now get that
information directly from the Festival object. In fact, the information on
the child object is now accessible by the parent object, and
vice versa. Later, when you start building more
complex business logic, you'll see how important and powerful
the relationship between objects becomes. See if you can
identify the parent in each of the following scenarios.